ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIBYAN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRIAN
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHEN
CHOI COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DAILY DAVIES LARA MIKE
FONG VENTS FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LOUIS
LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN DONALD
LISTEN PETRIE-NORRIS QUOTE
QUIRK-SILVA RAMOS REYES
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO SMITH STONE TAKING
BALLOT THERE AS THE VALLAPUDUA
ARE VOEPEL WALDRON REWARD WEBER
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DATES PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE NAME OF
GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. LET US GIVE THANKS TO
ALMIGHTY GOD. FOR HE IS GOOD FOR
HIS MERCY ENDURES FOREVER. THE
PARLIAMENT ALMIGHTY GOD BEFORE
THE BUSINESS OF THIS DAY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU. YOUR LOVE
SURROUNDS US YOUR MERCY OF HOLDS
US. YOUR GOODNESS BLESSES US
GRACIOUSLY GIVE THE MEMBERS AND
ALL WHO SERVE IN THIS ASSEMBLY
THE WISDOM AND COURAGE TO LEAD
US IN THE WAY OF RIGHTEOUSNESS.
AND PEACE. MAY THE RIPPLE EFFECT
OF THEIR DECISIONS BRING HOPE TO
ALL PEOPLE FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME. I MEAN. THANK YOU MA'AM
YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER BIGELOW. GOING.
THERE AND ZERO. WHAT. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
SUBMISSIONS ARE CRIMINAL
THURSDAY MARCH TENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE CINEMATIC NINETY
ON THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF LOOKS THE PART
OF THE DESK READING CLERK DAVID
BOWMAN READING WILL CALL THE
ROLL WAS CALLED CHRONICLE THE
ASSEMBLY MS REYES MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AMPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
F BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. WILLING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VINCE FONG. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM AND CHEN.
THE.
BUT.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW SSEMBLYMEMBERS
RADIOS ARAMBULA MEDINA RAMOS AND
WEBER TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER TO
THE FOLLOWING BILLS- COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN IS VERY IN
FROM THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE. AND
THEN BACK TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
THIRTY TWO AT THE WATER GARCIA
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
FOR THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND TO
THE MILITARY AND VETERANS OF
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. SB FORTY TWO
Y. CAO SKI FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE TO THE WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE S. J. R. FIVE WILK FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS MEMBERS OF I COULD HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS WE ARE
HAVING AN ISSUE WITH THE
MICROPHONES ON THE FLOOR. MS
RADIUS MS RACES MICROPHONE IS
WORKING. SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
MEMBERS THAT ARE PRESENTING
ITEMS COME UP TO MS REYES DESK
TO PRESENT THOSE ITEMS AND
MEMBERS IF YOU MUST PARTICIPATE
IN DEBATE. FEEL FREE TO UP Q.
HAD MS REYES DESK. CHAU
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION WITH
THESE PROCEDURES WHILE WE GET
THE MICROPHONE SITUATION FIXED.
HOPEFULLY YOU HEARD THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT MEMBERS.
AND MEMBERS WHILE I HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. WE DO HAVE GUESTS
WITH US IN THE GALLERY TODAY
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
STUDENTS AND STAFF WHO ARE
VISITING US TODAY FROM THE
AMERICAN FIELD SERVICE USE
EXCHANGE STUDY PROGRAM LET'S
WELCOME THEM TO THE ASSEMBLY
GALLERY.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING ACCORDING TO
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SIX. ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND ALL AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. ON RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SHALL BE
CONTINUED. ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS THREE. FOUR
FIVE AND SIX. PASS RETAIN. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THIS IS ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT BY MISS
GARCIA PRESENTING FROM. MS RATES
DESK THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA RELATIVE TO
BERNARD B. JAMES. MISS GARCIA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AG ARE TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH REQUEST A PRESIDENTIAL
PARDON AND EXPANSIONS OF MR
BERNARD JAMES RECORD. BERNARD
JAMES IS ONE IN CHICAGO IN
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. HIS MOTHER
WAS CREE ALL FROM K<c.cyan> HIS FATHER</c>
WAS MAKES AFRICAN AMERICAN IN
CHEROKEE BACKGROUND. MISTER
JAMES IS DRAFTED INTO THE ARMY
IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE AND
SERVED IN THE SEGREGATED SIX
FORTY FIRST SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIRST ORDINANCE COMPANY.
HOWEVER ALL BLACK UNITS WERE
STILL REQUIRED TO BE LED BY
WHITE COMMANDING OFFICERS. NOT
SURPRISINGLY THIS LED TO
RACIALLY MOTIVATED
DISCRIMINATION FROM THE WHITE
OFFICERS IN THESE UNITS. MISTER
JAMES EXPERIENCES THIS
DISCRIMINATION FIRST TIME WHEN
HE SPOKE IN PROTEST AGAINST
INACTION TAKEN BY HIS COMMANDING
OFFICER. THIS OFFICER HAD THE
MOTOR TO SOLDIER FOR ANSWERING
THE QUESTION TRUTHFULLY AFTER
THE OFFICER EXPLICITLY TOLD HIM
TO SPEAK REALLY. WHEN MR JAMES
PROTEST AT THE END JUST ACTIONS
TAKEN BY HIS WHITE OFFICER HE
TOO WAS THE MOTIVE AND- WAS ONE
OF EIGHTEEN SOLDIERS ARRESTED
AND SENTENCED TO EIGHTEEN YEARS
IN PRISON AND PRISON. FOR
SPEAKING TRUTHFULLY AND HONESTLY
AND STANDING UP FOR WAS JUST.
MISTER JAMES CENTERS WAS LIFTED
IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX AND THEN
HE RETURNED TO SERVE IN ITALY
DESPITE THE U. S. ARMY NEVER
OFFICIALLY PARDONING HIM. MISTER
JAMES WAS LISTED A WALL ON-
SEVEN DURING HIS TIME IN PRISON
AND DID NOT RECEIVE CREDIT FOR
HIS TIME SERVED DURING THIS TIME
. MISTER JAMES COURT MARTIAL WAS
COURT MARTIALED AND ULTIMATELY
AN ULTIMATE TIME SERVED IN
PRISON WAS RACIALLY. MOTIVATED
AND IS WRONG AND MUST BE
CORRECTED. MISTER JAMES JUST
TURNED A HUNDRED AND ONE ANY AS
ONE WAS FOR HIS BIRTHDAY THAT IS
RECORD BE EXPENSIVE FOR HE HE
PASSES ON. MISTER JAMES IS THERE
TO HAVE HIS RECORD EXPUNGED OR
IN THIS LAST TIME WHICH IS WHY
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
URGE. CONGRESS TO ACT SWIFTLY IN
THIS CASE. TWO CHAINS BEGAN TO
REBUILD HIS LIFE. BEGAN WORKING
AS AN ENGINEER AND ENGAGE IN
ACTIVISM AS A MEMBER OF THE
CATHOLIC SOCIAL JUSTICE MINISTRY
AND FRIENDSHIP HOUSE. UPON
MOVING TO LOS ANGELES MISTER
JAMES EMPLOYED HAS ENGINEERING
SKILLS THAT WERE COVETED BY THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY. HE WORKED ON
BOTH THE APOLLO AND THE- MERCURY
SPACE EXPLORATIONS. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE MISTER JAMES OF
THE MATTER JUST LIKE MINE AND
OFTENTIMES AS WORK WITH OUR
LOCAL YOU TO HELP THEM GET
THROUGH THE MATH ANXIETY TO
ENSURE THIS AND HOLD THEM BACK.
AS THE MARCH SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE U. S. ARMY AND
FOR MISTER JAMES AND THE FAMILY
OF OFFICIAL CHANGE OF HIS
SERVICE RECORD. THE EIGHTEEN
MONTHS HE WAS UNJUSTLY
INCARCERATED ENLISTED IT WILL
HAVE BEEN CORRECTED. BUT IS A
LOSS THAT IS CANNOT BE FULLY
STRICKEN UP FROM HIS RECORD
WITHOUT CONGRESSIONAL ACTION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BOARD THAT
CARRIES A WILL STATUS IS NOT
HAVE A THIRTY TO CONVEY AN
OFFICIAL PARDON. H. E. R. TWENTY
SEVEN ASK PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN TO
PARDON MR JAMES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND OFFICIALLY EXPUNGED
THIS INCIDENT FROM HIS RECORD
AND BEING JUSTICE ONCE AND FOR
ALL FOR THE BURN OUR FAMILY.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL HONOR MR
JAMES AND IS SERVICING WILL WERE
TO AND MOST IMPORTANTLY HONOR
HIM IS CALLING FOR ALWAYS
STANDING UP FOR WHAT'S RIGHT
EVEN IN THE FACE OF ADVERSITY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS GARCIA
MISS CHRISSY WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER SEA IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THIS RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS THIS IS AJ ARE THEREFORE
WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
ON S. H. A. R. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THE AG ARE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS AND A STAND AT THE
MICROPHONE ISSUE HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED. WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. YOU
MAY PRESENT FROM YOUR DESKS
MEMBERS. HIS FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT ACR ONE FIFTY BY MR THIS
AREA AND THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS AREA RELATIVE TO THE
PERSIAN NEW YEAR. THE SERVICE
AREA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ACR ONE FIFTY THE NOTO'S
PERSIAN NEW YEAR RESOLUTION THIS
RESOLUTION PROCLAIMS THE
TRADITIONAL PERSIAN NEW YEAR
BEGINNING ON THE VERNAL EQUINOX
AND CELEBRATES THE FIRST DAY OF
SPRING AS NOTICE IN DOING SO
THIS ANCIENT TRADITION CONTINUES
TO EXTEND ITS HOPE FOR PEACE
SOLIDARITY AND NEW BEGINNINGS
FOR EVERYONE ESPECIALLY FOR
CALIFORNIANS SINCE WILL SERVE
CELEBRATING IT. IN SACRAMENTO
TODAY. RIGHT NOW COLLEAGUES I'M
CERTAIN YOU KNOW WHAT NOTICE
MEANS AFTER ABOUT NINE YEARS OF
REPEATING THE SAME THING TO YOU
TO ALL OF YOU. IT IS A IT IS
CELEBRATED AND OBSERVED BY OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PEOPLE
WORLDWIDE INCLUDING THE
COUNTRIES OF IRAN INDIA
AFGHANISTAN ALBANIA AMONG
OTHERS. INCLUDING PARTS OF
CENTRAL ASIA. NOTO'S GIVES
EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF ETHNIC
CULTURAL RELIGIOUS OR ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
HOPE FOR A PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR.
TODAY HAVE PRESENTED YOU EACH
WITH SABZI OR SPROUTING GROUSE
GRASS WHICH IS A PROMINENT ITEM
THAT IS DISPLAYED ON A HAFT SEEN
TABLE THE PLANT SYMBOLIZES
REBIRTH GROWTH AND NEW LIFE.
THESE LANTS WILL DIE QUICKLY
AFTER A FEW DAYS HOWEVER I HOPE
THAT YOU USE THESE POTS TO GROW
NEW PLANTS IMPRESE EMBRACING NEW
BEGINNINGS. COLLEAGUES NOTICED
IS A WONDERFUL CELEBRATION WHICH
HAS BROUGHT MANY DIFFERENT
CULTURES TOGETHER- I FOR ONE AS
A CHRISTIAN MINORITY. HAVING
BEEN RAISED IN IRAN. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY OF SEEING HOW OUR
CHRISTIAN HERITAGE HERITAGE OF.
RITUALS OF THE EASTER WERE
CELEBRATED IN IRAN INCORPORATING
NOTICE. AND SO MY MOTHER WOULD-
GROW A FLAT BED OF THIS BY THE
SIZE OF MAYBE ABOUT A LARGE
PLATE AND THEN AFTER IT HAD.
REACHED A CERTAIN HEIGHT SHE
WOULD START PLACING THE EASTER
EGGS ON IT THAT WAY
INCORPORATING BOTH DIFFERENT
CULTURES AND A LOT OF ARMENIAN
HOUSEHOLDS ACTUALLY DID THAT.
AND IT WAS AMAZING TO SEE IN A
PLACE WHERE TODAY UNFORTUNATELY
IS SEEN AS A VERY VILE NATION
WITH ITS REGIME. HOW VARIOUS%
MINORITY CULTURES WERE ABLE TO
SPROUT AND BE. VERY PROSPEROUS
FOR A LONG TIME SO I LOOK BACK
AT THAT AND- YOU HOPE THAT ONE
DAY WE DO HAVE. OUR NATIONS THAT
WILL GO BACK TO WHERE THEY WERE-
WELCOMING NATIONS THAT ALLOWED
GROWTH OF ALL MINORITY GROUPS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
MINORITY GROUPS- WITH THAT IDEA
. ASK FOR THE FORCE FIRST ROLL
CALL TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN MR GABRIEL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I- TO RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF ACR FIFTY ONE ONE
FIFTY ONE I THINK ARE. CALLING
FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF THE FOUR
OH FIVE FOR VERY DILIGENTLY
BRINGING THIS FORWARD EVERY YEAR
OR AS WE REFER TO HIM IN THE
VALLEY I DREAM JUNE THANK YOU
FOR. CARRYING THE FLAG ON THIS
EVERY YEAR I'M VERY PROUD TO
REPRESENT A VERY VIBRANT AND
DIVERSE MIDDLE EASTERN COMMUNITY
IN THE WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
. WHO LOVES TO CELEBRATE THIS
HOLIDAY. AND I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE TOUCHED ON IT THE
THEMES OF UNITY OF RENEW ALL. OF
PIECE OF SOLIDARITY. ARE SO
APPROPRIATE AND HE MENTIONED HOW
IT HAS BECOME PART OF PRACTICE
BY MANY FAITH TRADITIONS THAT
INCORPORATION. THE SYMBOLISM OF
EASTERN NO ROOTS THERE SO MANY
OF MY FRIENDS IN THE PERSIAN
JEWISH COMMUNITY WHO ALSO
CELEBRATE THIS HOLIDAY. WHICH
TOUCHES ON MANY OF THE THEMES OF
THE PASSOVER HOLIDAY THAT THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY CELEBRATES
AROUND THIS TIME. MY STAFF WAS
VERY PRIVILEGED TO GO YESTERDAY
TO A LOCAL MOSQUE TO CELEBRATE
THEM. AND SO IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
HOLIDAY THAT THAT HELPS TO BRING
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER AND I THINK
IT'S SO EMBLEMATIC OF THE WORK
THAT WE TRY TO DO HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BRING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES TOGETHER. IN
THE SPIRIT OF UNITY AND
FRIENDSHIP AND MUTUAL RESPECT SO
WITHOUT WOULD URGE IN A STRONG
AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE FIFTY. THANK
YOU MISS GABRIEL MISTER MAYES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I TO RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FIFTY MEG
IS. A QUICKLY GIVE YOU A STORY
OF MAYBE PERSONAL GROWTH- FOR ME
WHEN I. FIRST GOT ELECTED AND
CAME HERE ON THIS FLOOR FOR
SELECTED TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY FIFTEEN I REMEMBER WHEN
THIS ITEM CAME UP. AND I WAS
LIKE WHAT KINDA. HIPPIE NEW AGE
THE THING IS THIS- THAT WERE
ABOUT TO. HEAD TO VOTE ON WELL
CACHO SPOKE IN FAVOR OF IT SO I
GUESS IT HAD TO BE. GOOD FAST
FOUR TO SEVEN YEARS EIGHT YEARS
WHATEVER WHEREVER AT NOW AND-
I'M VERY TO A PERSIAN GIRL
JUMPING OVER FIRE. I'VE GOT A
TABLE OUR HOUSE WITH THE SEVEN
**** ON IT. YESTERDAY HAD ALL
THE FAMILY OVER EATING GONNA
SABZI. AND FEST IN JUNE. SO IT'S
AMAZING WHAT'S HAPPENED OVER THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS THIS IS. A
QUITE- QUITE LITERALLY A NEW
BEGINNING. A NEW YEAR. AND SO I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FIFTY
. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES I SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. THE AUTHORS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
TUCKWELL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WHAT A PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN ACR ONE SIXTY BY MR MATHIS
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO DOWN SYNDROME
AWARENESS MISTER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO INTRODUCE ACR ONE SIXTY
IN. PARTICIPATION WITH- DEAR
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. WHO USUALLY CHAMPIONS
THIS ONE. CR ONE SIXTY
PROCLAIMS MARCH TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO MARCH TWENTY SIX.
AS CALIFORNIA DOWNTURN AWARENESS
WEEK AND MARCH TWENTY FIRST THIS
CALIFORNIA DOWN SYNDROME DAY. AS
A PARENT WHOSE CHILD IS PART OF
THE IT D. COMMUNITY I KNOW FIRST
HAND THE MANY CHALLENGES FACING
THOSE WITH DOWN SYNDROME. IT IS
CRUCIAL THAT THE LEGISLATOR
RECOGNIZES THESE CHALLENGES BIG
KNOWLEDGES THE PARTICIPATION OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN SYNDROME
IN SOCIETY AND HELPS THEM
FULFILL THEIR PERSONAL POTENTIAL
. THE LEGISLATOR ALSO HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT AND
SUPPORT THOSE WITHIN THE IT D.
COMMUNITY WHO ARE OFTEN DELIVERY
TARGETED AND MORE LIKELY TO FALL
VICTIMS. OF ABUSE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. I
AM PROUD TO STAND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS THE
ISLAND IN THIS BIPARTISAN
MEASURE AND TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WITHIN THE IT D.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS. MR GRAYSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY IS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF ACR ONE SIXTY.
HONORING CALIFORNIA DOWN
SYNDROME AWARENESS DAY AND WEEK.
DESPITE THEIR CHROMOSOMAL
DIFFERENCES INDIVIDUALS LIVING
WITH DOWN SYNDROME ATTEND SCHOOL
THEY GO TO WORK THEY PARTICIPATE
IN DECISIONS THAT AFFECT
THEMSELVES HAVE MEANINGFUL
RELATIONSHIPS THEY VOTE AND THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE SOCIETY AND
MANY WONDERFUL WONDERFUL WAYS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO BE RAISED IN A
HOUSEHOLD WITH MY **** WITH MY
SISTER SHERRY WHO LIVES WITH
DOWN SYNDROME. FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS AND
RECOGNITION OF THE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITH DOWN SYNDROME MAKE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
TO ACR ONE SIXTY. THANK YOU MISS
GRAYSON AYE MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR- ONCE AGAIN
BRINGING THIS TO OUR AWARENESS I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT- I'M VERY
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT. MY- MY
CAREER BEGAN IN THE FIELD OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND-
CONSEQUENTLY I WAS ABLE TO. MEET
HIM AND LEARN AND ASSOCIATE WITH
MANY OF THOSE WITH DOWN SYNDROME
ONE THING THE NEEDS THAT WE ALL
NEED TO BE REMINDED AS THEY HAVE
SOMETHING VERY VALUABLE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO US IT DOESN'T JUST
SYMPATHY THAT THEY ASK FOR ITS
GENUINE ENGAGEMENT. THEY HAVE
THE SAME EMOTIONS THAT WE DO AND
THEY RECOGNIZED ME AND
RECOGNIZED WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
CHALLENGE EVERYBODY ON THIS
FLOOR EVERYONE OF YOU. SO BEFORE
THIS YEAR'S OUT TO SHAKE THE
HAND OF SOMEONE WITH DOWN
SYNDROME. IT WILL CHANGE YOUR
LIFE YOU'LL MAKE THEIR LIVES
MORE ENRICHED AND YOURS AS WELL.
AND I THINK THOSE FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND PLEASE- HARDLY
SUPPORT THIS POPULATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
LACKEY MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISS BAKER
MEMBERS I RISE- TO REALLY
JOYFULLY- RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION. THE FRESNO
CLOVIS AREA HAS A WONDERFUL
ASSOCIATION OF DOWN SYNDROME
FAMILIES AND EVERY YEAR THERE IS
A CELEBRATION OF THE SWEET YOUNG
DEAR CHILDREN. WE GET TOGETHER
LARGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE SHOW UP
AND WE DO EXACTLY WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SUGGESTED WE DON'T
JUST SHAKE THEIR HANDS WE GIVE
THEM A BIG HUG WE LAUGH WE HAVE
FUN TOGETHER AND THERE ARE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO
SHOW UP IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THESE FAMILIES TO LET THESE
YOUNGSTERS KNOW THAT WE CARE AND
LOVE THEM AND TO STAND UP FOR
THEM AGAINST THAT SOMETIMES THE
BIGOTRY. M. THE ABUSE THAT THAT
THEY RECEIVE AND SO I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN THIS AND- ALSO
APPRECIATE MET MR LACKEY
SUGGESTION- BUT I'D GO ONE STEP.
FURTHER I GIVE A GREAT BIG HUG
THEY LOVE IT THEY'RE THE
SWEETEST LITTLE PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD. THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISTER MATHIS YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH. THANK YOU MEMBERS- MYSTERY
GUEST FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS MISTER MATHIS IS ASKING
THE VIRTUAL BE ABLE FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS FOR COOPER CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE YOUR OLDER
SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ADDED. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY YES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN H. R.
NINETY FIVE. CORKERY HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DAY MYSTERY THIS.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER-
AND I RISE THIS AFTERNOON TO
PRESENT HOUSE RESOLUTION HOUSE
RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE. WHICH
DECLARES MARCH TWENTY THIRD TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AS
AGRICULTURE DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS YEAR LET US
HIGHLIGHT THE VITAL ROLE OF
AGRICULTURE IN FUELING OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY. AND FEEDING
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS A
MODEL OF PRODUCTIVITY OF
INNOVATION AND EFFICIENCY. OUR
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS SET THE
BAR HIGH HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AS
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE. THE COMMITTEE- I'VE
TOURED AND TRAVELED THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE I HAVE BEEN JOINED BY
MANY OF YOU TO MEET SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WHO GROW OUR FOOD FARMERS
AND RANCHERS FARMWORKERS.
ADVOCACY IN SOME COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THERE IS NO.
NO PARALLEL FOR CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE NOT IN THE UNITED
STATES OR ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
WORLD. THE MOST OBVIOUS FACT
ABOUT OUR STATE'S AGRICULTURE IS
EXTRAORDINARY. THIS DIVERSITY.
AS OF NOW- OUR STATE WE PRODUCE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND SOME
DIFFERENT COMMODITIES HAS OVER
SEVENTY THOUSAND FARMS AND
RANCHES OF WHICH NEARLY FOUR
FIFTHS OUR INDIVIDUAL OR FAMILY
OWNED. AS THE NATION'S LEADER IN
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS WE SHIP
SOME BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH
OF FOOD SOME COMMODITIES AROUND
THE WORLD EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE STRONG
AND IS RESILIENT. WE DO HOWEVER
FACE CHALLENGES. RECENTLY WE'VE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE IMPACTS OF
CONGESTION AT OUR PORTS. EVEN AS
COVER NINETEEN CLIMATE CHANGE AN
UNPRECEDENTED WILDFIRES ATTESTED
THIS INDUSTRY'S CAPACITY. AND
YET ACROSS OUR STATE FARMERS
CONTINUE TO PLANT. WORKERS
CONTINUE TO HARVEST SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS COULD KEEP EATING.
MOVING FORWARD WE MUST KEEP
INNOVATING INNOVATIVE SO THAT
OUR AGRIC AG INDUSTRY CAN
COMPETE IN A GLOBAL MARKET. WE
MUST IMPROVE OUR WATER
MANAGEMENT AND WATER STORAGE
CAPACITY. SO CROPS THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO FLOURISH IN ARE
DROUGHT PRONE STATE. AND FINALLY
WE MUST DO MORE TO PROTECT THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HARD
WORKING FRONTLINE WORKERS WHO
GROW OUR FOOD. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW I'M THE SON OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS. IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME
TO CALIFORNIA IN SEARCH OF
OPPORTUNITY AND A BETTER LIFE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. THEY WORK
HARD IN THE FIELDS SO THAT I CAN
HAVE A CHANCE AT A BETTER LIFE.
IN THE SAME STORY IS TRUE FOR
MILLIONS OF FARMWORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY AS
A STATE. SO WE MUST MAKE SURE
THAT THE DOOR OF OPPORTUNITY THE
DOOR TO OPPORTUNITY REMAINS OPEN
. HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY TOO MANY
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS FACE
CHALLENGES AT WORK AND IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. IN MANY IF NOT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA'S RULE
AGRICULTURAL REGIONS OF OUR
STATE POVERTY AND LACK OF
ADEQUATE HOUSING PREVAILS. YOU
WILL FARMWORKERS PLAY A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN WORKING TO FEED
CALIFORNIANS FOOD AND SECURITY.
IS AMONG THE MANY CHALLENGES
THEY FACE DAILY IN ADDITION TO
FACE THE WILD FIRES AND TOXIC
AIR QUALITY CONDITIONS
INCREASING HEAT WAVES AND- THE
ECONOMIC IN AND HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF AN ON GOING
GLOBAL PANDEMIC. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT ALL FARMWORKERS ARE TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT BOTH ON
THE JOB AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE MUST KEEP IN MIND THAT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF ALWAYS ALWAYS LIFTING
EVERYONE UP AS WE RISE. AND TO
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS
RANCHERS FARM WORKERS AND
EVERYONE ELSE WHO HELPED MAKE
OUR AG INDUSTRY THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD. WE ARE PROFOUNDLY
GRATEFUL MISTER SPEAKER WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE THE FIRST CALL.
ROLL CALL OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE DAY. IT'S A DAY OF
RESILIENCE AND STRENGTH ON THE
WEST STEPS OF THE CAPITOL THIS
COMING WEDNESDAY STARTING AT TEN
THIRTY AM AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS REAVIS WAS TO BE
APPROVED BY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
BIGGER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO SUPPORT HR NINETY FIVE.
I IT MYSELF- HAD A MALE WHO WAS
A PRESIDENT. WHO WORKED REALLY
HARD IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. MY
UNCLE WAS A FARM WORKER MY DAD
MY MOM BOTH WORKED ON A FARM AND
TAUGHT US TO WORK REALLY HARD ON
OUR AG INDUSTRY- IT WAS IT WAS
BEAUTIFUL THINGS I GOT TO LEARN
HOW TO DRIVE MY TRUCK. YOUR
FARMERS NOW ASK ME LIKE GOD HOW
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
KNOW WORKING ON THE FARM BECAUSE
THEY COULD TELL BY. THE FOLKS
THAT WHEN THEY GRAB A PIECE OF
FRUIT THEY DON'T WASH IT THEY
JUST GRABBED A BRUSH IT OFF ON
THEIR JACKET NEEDED RIGHT THAT'S
HOW WE GREW UP- I RECENTLY WAS
AT A- DINNER- TWO WEEKS AGO AND-
IN LOS ANGELES. AND WE HAD ALL
THESE FOLKS FROM FROM NEW YORK
SITTING AT THE TABLE. AND I HAD
MY DINNER AND I AND I. WAS NOT.
IN THE MOOD OF HAVING DESSERT
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST BERRIES AND
STRAWBERRIES. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED BECAUSE WE ALWAYS HAVE
IT. BUT THEY THEY LOOKED AT ME
AND THEY SAY HEY IF YOU'RE NOT
GONNA EAT DOT DO YOU MIND I SAID
YEAH I PASSED IT OVER. SHE GOES.
WERE FROM. THAT'S GOLD. AND WE
TAKE THAT FOR GRANTED SOMETIMES
HERE RIGHT WE'VE BECAUSE IT'S
ALWAYS IN OUR FACE- BUT IT WAS
IT WAS NICE TO HEAR BECAUSE I
START ASKING A LITTLE DEEPER
LIKE. WHAT WHY WHY IS A GOAL DO
YOU. BECAUSE BY THE TIME IT GETS
TO US IT'S YOU KNOW. DAYS LATER
OR WEEKS LATER. BUT AGAIN I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT WE TAKE OUR
ACT FOR GRANTED. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT. OUT OF EVERY THREE
OUT OF OUT OF. OUT OF EVERY FIVE
JOBS IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY. ZAGG
RELATED. YOU GO TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS STADIUM. THOSE
DOGS IT'S READING GUESTS WERE
COMES FROM IT COMES FROM SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY YOU LOOK AT THAT
SIDE OUT THIS GIANT STADIUM YES
WERE COMES FROM IT COMES FROM A
FARMER A FARM WORKER AND THAT
COMES FROM SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY SO
I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT
BECAUSE- WE LOOK AROUND AND
WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH BAG IN
OUR COMMUNITY BUT WE DON'T
REALIZE IT BECAUSE IT JUST
PASSES US UP. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR ECONOMY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR JOBS. LET ME JUST
ADD THAT IN CHEROKEE COUNTY TWO
THOUSAND AG RELATED JOBS. WE ARE
SOCIETY THAT CAN NOT LIVE OR
FUNCTION WITHOUT FOOD SO
pIMPORTANT TO OUR STATE AND OUR
WORLD AND OUR WORLD RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS WHY THIS BODY NEEDS TO
CONTINUE SUPPORT THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE SO THAT THEY COULD
CONTINUE TO SECURE FOOD SUPPLY
THAT KEEPS FAMILIES BED HERE AND
ACROSS THE GLOBE. WE ARE
CELEBRATING AG DAY THIS WEEK AND
I WANT US TO THINK ABOUT WHERE
OUR FOOD COMES FROM AND HOW
IMPORTANT OUR FARMERS AND
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. ARE MAKING
MAKING SURE THAT WE ENJOY THAT
DAY IN DAY OUT SO TODAY I ASK
THIS BOARD TO SUPPORT. HR NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
COULD WELL. MISTER MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR NINETY FIVE AG
DAY. AS THE. LONG SERVING VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S A
DEEP WATER THAT WE DO HAVE THIS
DAY. AND FOR SOMEONE FROM A
DISTRICT THAT HOSTS THE WORLD AG
EXPO. EVERY YEAR WHO REPRESENTS
OVER FORTY THOUSAND. AG JOBS
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT DAY
IN CALIFORNIA WE OFTEN FORGET IS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOAQUIN
MENTION. GLOBALLY CALIFORNIA'S
NUMBER ONE. WE PRODUCE MORE WE
DO IT CLEANER WE DO A BETTER WE
DO IT SAFER THAN ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE WHOLE ENTIRE WORLD. BUT
EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IS UNDER ATTACK. AND
I USED TO COURAGE ALL THE
MEMBERS TO COME OUT ON WEDNESDAY%
. THE SOME OF THESE FAMILIES ME
SOME OF OUR FUTURE FARMERS OF
AMERICA MEET THE PEOPLE. THAT
PUT EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE
INTO PROVIDING FOOD AND FOOD AND
FIBER. FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES
. MEMBERS WITH THAT SIMPLY ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT THIS COME OUT
WEDNESDAY SHE WHAT GOES ON IF
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN ON AN
AGRICULTURAL TOWER IN MET THE
FAMILIES THE PUT EVERYTHING THAT
THEY HAVE FROM GENERATION TO
GENERATION PLEASE ENCOURAGE YOU
GO OUT ON ONE. THANK YOU. AND MR
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES MPS RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS SOUTHEAST SACRAMENTO
COUNTY BEYOND BEING SPECTACULAR
THIS TIME OF YEAR IS SO
PRODUCTIVE IN AGRICULTURE CATTLE
WINE GRAPES PEARS AW AQUACULTURE
. ALL MANNER OF PRODUCE WALNUTS-
SO MANY DIFFERENT THINGS BUT ON
THIS MORNING WHEN WE FIND
OURSELVES HIM DAN. SO THAT WE
WILL SPEND MORE TIME IN THE
HISTORIC WEST CAP WEST WING I DO
WANT TO NOTE THAT HIGH ON THE
WALL OF THE ROTUNDA. YOU SEE A
BUNCH OF COLUMNS UP THERE WITH
WHAT LOOKED LIKE BANNERS. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY WHEN YOU HAVE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS HERE LOOK UP
LOOK CLOSELY. THOSE COLUMNS ARE
TOPPED BY THIRTY TWO
CORNUCOPIAS. HORNS OF PLENTY AND
THE BANNER GREAT BETWEEN THEM UP
THERE ON THE WALL THE ROTUNDA IS
ALL MANNER OF CALIFORNIA
PRODUCE. SHOW FOR THE LONGEST
TIME AS YOU POINT OUT WE ARE THE
CORNUCOPIA THE HORN OF PLENTY TO
THE WORLD. AS A MISTER MATHIS IS
POINTED OUT THIS IS CALIFORNIA
SO PRODUCTIVE IN OUR
AGRICULTURE. AND IT IS NOT LOST
UPON THOSE THAT MADE THIS
CAPITAL IT IS BEEN A ARTIFACT OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SO LONG. AND IT'S
RIGHT THERE- TO BE HOLD OVERHEAD
WHENEVER YOU'RE IN PASSED TO THE
ROTUNDA. THERE IS CLEANEST
FLORA. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF H. R. AT
NINETY FIVE. AND I HAVE A SNEAKY
SUSPICION THAT ALL OF US ARE
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY-
BECAUSE WE SHOULD. BECAUSE THAT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INTO THE
WORLD'S FOOD SUPPLY. BUT I WOULD
JUST ASK AS WE START COMMITTEES
UP. FOR THIS LEGISLATIVE SEASON
. THAT WOULD ADD COMES WITH
CONCERNS WE TALK ABOUT WATER. WE
TALK ABOUT PESTICIDES WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WORKERS. THAT WE
SUPPORT ADDED INTO THAT WE DON'T
JUST SUPPORT ACT TODAY BECAUSE
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO. WE
STAY FOCUSED AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT GROW
OUR FOOD NEED OUR SUPPORT NOT
JUST IN AN HR. BUT EVERY DAY SO
AS THESE BILLS COME THROUGH
COMMITTEES. AND AG HAS CONCERNS
FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF. THANK THAT
SERIOUS. THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
WAY OF LIFE AND SOME OF OUR
MORE. URBAN FRIENDS. BUT OUR WAY
OF LIFE. REASON WITH THEM TAKE
THE CONCERNS SERIOUS AND SUPPORT
ACT THEN AS WELL THANK YOU. HE
WAS FLOOR MR VOEPEL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SO I REPRESENT A
LARGELY RURAL DISTRICT SO ON
BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS I
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT HR NINETY
FIVE IN HERE'S THEIR VOICE.
THANK YOU. THE MICROPHONES ARE
INDEED WORKING THANK YOU. YOU
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
CANNOT BELIEVE THAT BUT AGAS
IMPORTANT THINK ABOUT EVERYTHING
WE CAN GET WHERE COMES FROM AG
AG OVER FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
PUBLIC CLOSE TO SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA OUR
BIGGEST COMMODITY BIGGER THAN
TECH. IT IS SO HARD SOMETIMES
YOUR FOOD DOESN'T COME FROM
ALBERTSONS KROGER BILL THERE
SAFELY IT COMES FROM TAGS IN MY
DISTRICT WE GROW 20% THE ONE
GREAT THING CALIFORNIA MORE THAN
HAPPENS AND ONLY THINK ABOUT
THIS- IT'S MORE THAN THE STATE
OF OREGON WATCH TO COMBINE AND
THEY'LL USE THOSE HARVESTERS
DRIVERS GREAT. SIX RATE WITHOUT
THE YEAR THE REST OF TIME IS
IDEAL BUT YET- WE HAVE CALLED
THE SAYS YOU CAN'T USE THAT
ENGINE TRACTOR THE LONGER YOU
MORE YOU CAN USE IT. ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE WORLD AT THE STATE
OR THE U. S. BUT NOT IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S ALWAYS A
TOUGH BATTLE SO I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIPPING IT IS
GRACE AGDAY BUT THERE'S SO MUCH
HELP
OUR LARGEST INDUSTRY HOW CAN WE
HELP BAG AND MAKE HIM SIXTY. TO
GET IT DONE IT WILL WANT HEALTHY
FOOD THIS OLD PORT AND RELATED
THINK ABOUT IT BUT THERE'S NOT
PRODUCTIONS FRUITS WE LEAD THE
WORLD WE FEED THE U. S. IN THE
WORLD SO YOU'LL PLEASE SUPPORT
AG. TO SUPPORT HR NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS COOPER
. I SEE NO MEMBERS SEEKING MR. I
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU THANK THE
SPEAKER MEMBERS ON GOING TO TRY
TO COME WITH OUR WEEK. I WANT TO
TELL OUT WHAT WHEN I FOR SHOWED
UP HERE THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
NINE YEARS AGO OR SO GOING ON
TEN. I REMEMBER HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH UP SOME FOLKS
UP HERE WHO WERE. AND I IT'S-
NOT FROM THE BIG CITIES. AB I
MENTIONED THAT I WAS FROM FRESNO
AND THAT WE HAD LOTS OF
AGRICULTURE IN. THIS INDIVIDUAL
SAID OLD. THAT'S WONDERFUL MAYBE
I COULD COME AND TAKE A LOOK AT
AGRICULTURE I DON'T KNOW A LOT
ABOUT IT. AND I SAID SURE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME ANYTIME YOU
WANT. THIS INDIVIDUAL SAID I'VE
ALWAYS WANTED. TO SEE A REYES
AND BRUSH. WE HAVE SOME
EDUCATING TO DO. IT'S NOT JUST
IN THE GROCERY STORE BUT IT
REALLY IS ABOUT HOW ALL OF THIS
COMES TOGETHER AND IT COMES
TOGETHER BECAME BIG BECAUSE
PEOPLE IN AGRICULTURE. THEY ARE
THE MOST RESILIENT THEY ARE THE
MOST HARD WORKING DAY CREATE
SOMETHING FROM THE GROUND THEY
LOVE THE- OUR ENVIRONMENT THEY
TAKE REALLY GOOD CARE OF IT. AND
QUITE FRANKLY OUT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT IF WE THINK THAT.
WHAT'S VALUABLE TO US FOR
NUTRITION. YOU KNOW COME COMES
OUT OF THE PACKAGE OR BOTTLE
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE MISSING IT.
AND SO I ENCOURAGE YOU ALL FROM
THE AGRICULTURAL AREAS TO REACH
OUT TO THOSE WHO ARE MORE URBAN.
AND ARE. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE BASICALLY A CUSTOM TO
GOING TO THE- TO THE GROCERY
STORE AND HAVING. PARTICULARLY
IN A TIME RIGHT NOW WHERE WE ARE
SEEING INFLATION HITTING THE BUT
THE PRICES. OF FOOD THIS IS
REALLY A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR
ALL OF US. AND I WANT TO ECHO.
THE COMMENTS OF MEMBERS HERE WHO
HAVE SAID. IT'S ONE THING TO
STAND UP IN SUPPORT OF
AGRICULTURE WITH A AT A
RESOLUTION LIKE THIS. IT'S
ANOTHER THING TO LISTEN TO
AGRICULTURE IN THOSE COMMITTEES
AND WHEN THEY HAVE CONCERNS ARE
WHEN THEY BRING AN IDEA FORWARD
. LISTEN TO THEM. RESPECT THEM
FOR WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT THEY
DO. AND LEARN FROM THEM.
PRECIADO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF A RESOLUTION
BUT LET'S ALSO RESOLVE. TO LIVE
. IN FRONT OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
PEOPLE WHEN IT REALLY MATTERS IN
OUR COMMITTEES TO LISTEN TO HEAR
AND UNDERSTAND IF NOT WE'RE JUST
SIMPLY SUPPORTING A RESOLUTION
AND SO MUCH PAPERWORK WE NEED TO
BE THERE WHEN IT REALLY MATTERS
BUT IT'S A LIFE OR DEATH
AGRICULTURE THANK YOU FOR THE
RESOLUTION BUT ALSO TO ENCOURAGE
US. TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AGRICULTURE WHEN THEY COME TO US
AND COMMITTEES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS PATTERSON. I SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS ON THE ITEM.
MYSTERY THIS IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
FOUR O'CLOCK THE ROLE. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR NINETY FIVE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. LIKE
WELL. CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT PLEASE WELCOME
MAGGIE HAVE MEETING WHO IS IN
THE GALLERY FOR MISTER NAZARIAN
SNOW ROUTES RESOLUTION LET'S
PLEASE WELCOME HER. TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
EVERS BACK ON THE FLOWER FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. HR NINETY
SIX BY MR BIGELOW CLERK WILL
READ HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL SURVEYORS
WEEK. MISTER BIGELOW. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I'M
HONORED TO PRESENT H. R. NINETY
SIX WHICH RECOGNIZES THIS WEEK
AS NATIONAL SURVEYORS WEEK.
THERE ARE MORE THAN FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL SURVEYORS
IN THE UNITED STATES AND
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALONE.
SURVEYING IS THE ART OF SCIENCE
OF THE STAFF WISHING LAND
BOUNDARIES FOR OWNERSHIP OR
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES. SURVEYORS
HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES STATEMENTS
INFLUENTIAL CITIZENS AND SHAPERS
OF CULTURAL STANDARDS. SUCH A
NOTABLE SURVEYORS INCLUDE GEORGE
WASHINGTON ABRAHAM LINCOLN HENRY
DAVID THOREAU. WITHOUT THE WORK
OF SURVEYORS THE VERY BOUNDARIES
OF LAND THAT SHAPED OUR STATE
AND COUNTRY WOULD NOT EXIST. FOR
THOSE REASONS AND MORE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE CELEBRATE THE
HARD WORK AND ACHIEVEMENTS OF
SURVEYORS BY VOTING I'D ON H. R.
NINETY SIX AND I REQUEST THAT
THE WILL BE OPEN FOR COLLECTORS
. THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISTER
BIGELOW SESSION AT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
NINE CO AUTHOR SAT IT IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKEA VOICE
VOTE ON THE HR CLERK WILL PER ME
WILL TAKE INVOICE VOTE ON THIS
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE HAVE GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TO
MARK NATIONAL SURVEYORS WEEK ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW LET'S WELCOME THEM TO
THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO STAY ON
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
. AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
THIS IS A CA THREE. PRESENTED BY
MISTER KALRA AND THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
LIMIT THREE BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHER GENETICALLY THEIR
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT THREE THE CALIFORNIA
ABOLITION ACT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR KAMLAGER. MEMBERS THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IS LONG
OVERDUE. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION PROHIBITS SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE EXCEPT
TO PUNISH CRIME. AC THREE SEEKS
TO AMEND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION TO REMOVE SUCH
CONDITIONAL LANGUAGE ABOLISHING
FORCED LABOR AND INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
OVER NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN STATE PRISONS
AFTER AMERICANS ACCOUNT 420% OF
THE PRISON POPULATION OF LESS
THAN 6% OF CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
POPULATION. ALTHOUGH NO COURTS
EXPLICITLY INCLUDE LABOR AS A
CONDITION OF CRIMINAL SENTENCING
THERE IS AN EXPECTATION THAT
MANY INCARCERATED PEOPLE PERFORM
LABOR OFTENTIMES FOR AS LITTLE
AS EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR. TO SUSAN
TODAY TWELVE STATES PROHIBIT IN
SLAVEN AN INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
BUT EXCEPTION PROVISIONS FOR
CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT REMAIN NINE
STATES PERMIT INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE AS A CRIMINAL
PUNISHMENT CALIFORNIA BEING ONE
OF THEM. DISSOLVING THE REMNANTS
OF SLAVERY AND RACIAL INEQUALITY
IS MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
COLORADO PASSED A BALLOT MEASURE
THAT REMOVE SLAVERY AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE IS A
CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT FROM ITS
STATE CONSTITUTION. IN TWENTY
TWENTY VOTERS NEBRASKA AND UTAH
VOTED TO REMOVE PRISON SLAVERY
FROM THEIR STATE CONSTITUTIONS
THAT SAME YEAR U. S. SENATOR
MERKLEY OF OREGON INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION TO REMOVE INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE AS A PUNISHMENT FOR
CRIME FROM THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION. AC THREE WILL NOT
DEAL WITH COMMUNITY SERVICE
ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING PROGRAMS
THESE PROGRAMS STILL FUNCTION IN
STATES LIKE COLORADO WHERE
SIMILAR CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS HAVE TAKEN EFFECT.
THE NATURE OF THIS MEASURES ALSO
SO IMPORTANTLY SYMBOLIC OUR
CONSTITUTION SERVES AS THE
GUIDING PRINCIPLE FOR ALL OTHER
STATE LAWS. THERE IS NO PLACE
FOR SLAVERY FORCED LABOUR OR
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE ON OUR
BOOKS RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AC. THREE THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS FOR DESIRED
ABOUT THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO. AT A CA PASSES. MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE FILE
ITEMS THIRTEEN THROUGH FIFTEEN
PASS AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN THIS IS
SENATE BILL FIVE OH FOUR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL FIVE OH FOUR WITH A MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN ISSUE
BRIAN ON THE AMENDMENTS. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS BIGGER MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT FLOOR
MEMBERS FOR SB FIVE OH FOUR THIS
BILL HAS ALREADY COME OFF OF
THIS FLOOR TWICE BUT THESE CLEAN
UP AMENDMENTS SIMPLY REMOVE THE
QUESTION FROM THE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD THAT SAYS DO
YOU WANT TO BE A PERMANENT VOTE
BY MAIL VOTER. THAT QUESTION IS
NOW REDUNDANT BECAUSE EVERYBODY
IS A VOTE BY MAIL VOTER. THANK
YOU THANK YOUTO MY COLLEAGUES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS
OUT TO PRINT. BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE IS
THE CONSECUTIVE- CITY MEMBER
WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
ACRONYM PROBATE. AND THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CLICK WELL
. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS ADOPTED. CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
THIRTY I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SYMBOL SEVENTEEN FORTY FIVE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX I
SEVENTY ONE. NO ZERO. MEMBERS
QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HAVE
SEVERAL COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON. THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL MEET UPON A
GERMAN AND SWING SPACE ROOM
ELEVEN HUNDRED. BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE WILL MEET
AT TWO THIRTY PM IN ROOM FOUR
FOUR FOUR. BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FIVE WILL MEET AT TWO THIRTY IN
ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE WILL
MEET AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM. FOUR
FOUR SEVEN. AND THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE WILL MEET AT
THREE O'CLOCK. OR UPON CALL OF
THE CHAIR. IN ROOM. ONE TWENTY
SIX. MEMBERS OF THE QUORUM CALL
IS NOT LIFTED. THE QUORUM CALL
IS NOT. LIFTED WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED GERMANS
IN MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS SINGULAR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WHO HAVE. REQUESTED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR TAKER CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME WEARE
READY GERMAN TO MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL IS IN PLACE. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS RANA PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY DR
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
. TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY GRANDFATHER JEROME
LISLE RAPOPORT WHO PASSED AWAY
ON DECEMBER SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT THE AGE OF NINETY FOUR. I
WANTED TO SHARE HIS STORY TO
SHOW THE INFLUENCE THAT ONE CAN
HAVE ON OTHERS SUCH AS MY MOTHER
AND MYSELF TO SERVE THE PUBLIC
GOOD. MY GRANDFATHER WAS THE
GRANDSON OF EUROPEAN IMMIGRANTS
WHO CAME FROM GERMANY FEELING
PERSECUTED BECAUSE OF THEIR
JEWISH FAITH. THEY WOULD SETTLE
INTO NEW YORK CITY BEFORE AND
DURING THE DEPRESSION WHERE HE
WOULD GROW UP. AS A TEENAGER IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN FORTIES HE
IDOLIZED FDR WHO HE SAID HAD
SAVED AMERICA FROM THE DESPAIR
OF THE GREAT DEPRESSION. SO AT
THE AGE OF SIXTEEN MY
GRANDFATHER JEROME ENROLLED INTO
HARVARD THE VERY ALMA MATER THAT
FDR HAD SO THAT HE COULD ALSO BE
A PART TO CHANGE OUR WORLD. HE
WENT THERE ON A SPECIAL WARTIME
DEGREE TO BOTH SIMULTANEOUSLY
GET HIS UNDERGRADUATE AS WELL AS
HIS LAW DEGREE. AND IT WAS THERE
AT HARVARD IN THE EARLY FORTIES
THAT HE RECOGNIZED THAT THEY
WERE TEACHING PUBLIC POLICY IN A
VACUUM. THAT THEY WERE NOT
RECOGNIZING AND ACKNOWLEDGING
THE ENORMITY OF THE **** CRIMES
AND THE HOOK ATROCITIES THAT
WERE OCCURRING TO THE JEWISH
PEOPLE THAT HE ADVOCATED AND
FOUGHT FOR AND ESTABLISH THE
HARVARD LAW FOR. A FOREIGN THAT
WAS INTENDED TO BRING SOME OF
THE GREATEST MINDS IN SPEAKERS
TO HARVARD. OVER TIME THOSE
SPEAKERS HAVE INCLUDED THE
REVEREND DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR. INCLUDED IN THERE IS
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES RUTH
BADER GINSBURG THURGOOD MARSHALL
AND PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER. THAT
LAW SCHOOL SPEAKER SERIES IS
STILL GOING ON TODAY AND IS THE
LONGEST ACTING LAW SCHOOL
SPEAKER SERIES IN AMERICA. WHILE
HE WAS THERE IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES IN BOSTON MY GRANDFATHER
BEGAN TO TAKE ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT FIRST IN CAMPAIGNS
BY WORKING ON JOHN HEINZ'S
MAYORAL CAMPAIGN AND SECONDS BY
WORKING TO MAKE SURE. THAT
BOSTON WAS CHANGING THE VERY
CITY COUNCILS AND SCHOOL BOARDS.
IT WAS ALSO DURING THAT TIME
THAT HE BEFRIENDED A YOUNG JOHN
FITZGERALD KENNEDY. ANY BECAME
HIS ASSISTANT CAMPAIGN MANAGER
AS HE TOOK ON THEN INCUMBENT
REPUBLICAN FOR THE UNITED STATES
SENATE SEAT. AFTER THAT ELECTION
MY GRANDFATHER FORMED THE
GREATER BOSTON REGIONAL COUNCIL
TO ENSURE THAT BOSTON WAS
PREPARING FOR THE FUTURE THROUGH
A THOUGHTFUL MODERNIZATION
EFFORT THAT HAS BEEN DESCRIBED
AS THE BIGGEST REDEVELOPMENT
EVER IN THE CITY OF BOSTON. MY
GRANDFATHER WAS ALSO A STRONG
BELIEVER IN THE POWER OF
PHILANTHROPY HE HELPS TO
ESTABLISH SEVERAL PROGRAMS TO
PROMOTE THAT BELIEF IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE HE ESTABLISHED THE
RAPAPORT URBAN FELLOWSHIP THAT
WOULD GRANT SCHOLARSHIPS TO
ELECTED STATE AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS IN THE GREATER BOSTON
AREA WHO WISH TO PURSUE A
MASTER'S DEGREE AT HARVARD'S
KENNEDY SCHOOL. HE ALSO
ESTABLISHED THE RAPAPORT
INSTITUTE AT HARVARD AS WELL AS
THE RAPPAPORT CENTER FOR LAW AND
PUBLIC POLICY AT BOSTON COLLEGE
WHICH CREATED A NETWORK OF
HUNDREDS OF CIVIC MINDED
INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD DEVOTE
THEMSELVES TO SERVING. THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY AS JUST ONE EXAMPLE
CURRENT BOSTON MAYOR MICHELLE WU
WAS A FORMER FELLOW. HE ALSO
WORKED WITH THE CURE ALZHEIMER'S
FUND DUE TO THE PAINFUL LOSS OF
HIS OWN MOTHER CORA TO THAT
DISEASE. MY MOTHER IS HIS SECOND
ELDEST CHILD. AND I AM HIS
OLDEST GRAND CHILD. I WILL
pWITH HIM SOAKING UP HIS WIT HIS
CHARM AND HIS INTELLIGENCE. I
WILL MISS HIS ADVICE AND HIS
WISDOM. HE WAS A BIG THINKER WHO
INVESTED IN AND BELIEVED IN THE
POTENTIAL AND BRILLIANCE OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS. I THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY GRANDFATHER JEROME
LISLE RAPPAPORT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR. MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE
QUORUM CALL AT THIS TIME. THAT
WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
SEATS MEMBERS TAKE ANY
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
HER RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
AND MS RAY S. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. TODAY
I RISE TO DURING THE MEMORY OF
DR TOM LEAVE IT ON. KNOWN AS DR
TOM GRADUATED FROM COLTON
SCHOOLS AND SAMPOERNA DINO
VALLEY COLLEGE AND CAPTURES
EDUCATION WITH A DOCTORATE FROM
UCLA. HE WAS AN ADMINISTRATOR
CAL STATE SAMPOERNA DINO FOR
NEARLY FORTY YEARS. AFTER TOM
WAS A PILLAR OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND LIVED A LIFE OF
SERVICE TO HIS COMMUNITY. THIRTY
SIX YEARS AGO HE WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH GUILLAIN BARR SYNDROME AND
SPENT THOSE LAST THIRTY SIX
YEARS IN A WHEELCHAIR. THAT IS
NOT WHAT DEFINED HIM HIS LOVE
FOR HIS COMMUNITY AND ESPECIALLY
FOR STUDENTS. WAS LEGENDARY HE
SERVED ON A NUMBER OF BOARDS. HE
WAS A TEACHER WITH THE RIALTO
AND WAS ON THE IN THE TEACHER
RIALTO TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
UNITED WAY EASTER SEALS SOCIETY
. OMNITRANS CATHOLIC CHARITIES
BUILDING START. HE'S ALSO ON THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR THE
COLTON JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SAMPOERNA DINO
MALACOLOGY OPS SAMITY NO DRUG
AND GANG TASK FORCE THE
CHANCELLOR'S CHICANO ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AT THE AT YOU SEE OUR
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF AMERICA
AND SISTER CITIES INTERNATIONAL
HE GOT ME. YEAH THE MOST ON. HE
SERVED IN THE PEACE CORPS IS A
YOUNG MAN AND WAS A CHARTER
MEMBER OF OUR LOCAL KIWANIS.
WHEN HE RETIRED FROM CAL STATE
SAN BERNARDINO IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN HE WAS COMMENDED FOR HIS
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS. IN THE FIELD
OF EDUCATION THROUGHOUT THE
INLAND EMPIRE. ONE OF HIS
LASTING CONTRIBUTIONS WAS THE
CREATION IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
OF THE INLAND EMPIRE FUTURE
LEADERS PROGRAM. EIGHT AND NINTH
GRADERS. SINCE ITS INCEPTION
MORE THAN FORTY FOUR HUNDRED
YOUNG STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETED
THE PROGRAM. WITH A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATE OF 99% FOR THOSE
ATTENDING ANY COLLEGE GOING RATE
OF 90% 101% OF THE FUTURE
LEADERS PROGRAM IS VOLUNTEER
WORK SOME OF THE GRADUATES OF
THIS PROGRAM INCLUDE TWO MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS REPRESENTATIVE
MACULAR AND REPRESENTATIVE I
WILL DO WEEKS. ALSO THE NUMBER
OF DOCTORS AND LAWYERS AND
PROFESSORS AND NONPROFIT
FOUNDERS. HIS EFFORTS HAVE
UPLIFTED THE COMMUNITY AND HE
HAS ABSOLUTELY GROWN YOU TO
LEADERS ACROSS THE INLAND EMPIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
INTERNATIONALLY. HIS MOST RECENT
PROJECT STARTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR WITH THE SUSHI
FOUNDATION PROVIDING FREE HEALTH
CLINICS FREE FOOD PANTRIES
THROUGHOUT SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
. DR TOM WAS A GREAT ENCOURAGER
GREAT MOTIVATOR. WHEN HE MET ONE
OF MY CLIENTS GEORGE WHO HAD
BEEN SHOT TWENTY SIXTEEN IT WAS
RENDERED A QUADRIPLEGIC. PAUL
GEORGE. SMILE HE SAID WHAT MEET
YOU THEY FIRST NOTICED THAT
WHEELCHAIR BUT IF YOU SMILE THEN
THE FIRST THING THEY WILL NOTICE
USE YOUR SMILE. AND THAT TIME ON
GEORGE WAS A SMILER. TOM WAS AN
IMPORTANT TREND. BOTH MYSELF AND
MY ENTIRE FAMILY. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE LILY OF FIFTY YEARS
MY DEAR FRIENDS. ALSO SURVIVED
BY HIS CHILDREN BUT THE PEACE
YET EVELYN AND TOM. HIS BROTHER
RAY RIVERA AS WELL AS HIS GRAND
CHILDREN WHOM HE LOVED
UNCONDITIONALLY. MEMBERS I ASKED
THAT WE JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF
DOCTOR TOLD ME THAT. AND MR
MEDINA YOU TOO ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE SHERMAN OF MEMORY THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I ALSO
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
DR TOM RIVERA. TOM WAS A GOOD
FRIEND WHO LIVED A LIFE OF
DEVOTION TO HIS COMMUNITY. HE
SERVED ON NUMEROUS COMMUNITY
BOARDS WHILE WORKING AT CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO AS
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS. DURING HIS YEARS THERE HE
CREATED SEVERAL PROGRAMS TO MET
MOTIVATE AND REPRESENTED
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN AND
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. TOM
POINTED TO THREE COMMUNITY
PROJECTS THAT HE WAS INVOLVED IN
AS IS MOST GRATIFYING
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THE INLAND
EMPIRE FUTURE LEADERS OF PROGRAM
THAT HE FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. WITH OTHER
EDUCATORS TO ADDRESS THE DROPOUT
RATE OF LATINO STUDENTS. THE
SUIT G. FOUNDATION WHICH CREATED
A FREE HEALTH CLINIC IN STAMINA
DINO OF FOOD PANTRY AND ASSISTED
VICTIMS OF AREA FIRES. AND
INITIATING THE SOUTH COLTON ORAL
HISTORY PROJECT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH CAL STATE SAMBAR TO DINO
FILE LIBRARY AND FELLOW
EDUCATORS. TOM AND I BOTH SERVED
AS PEACE CORPS VOLUNTEERS IN
COLOMBIA. THE WE SERVED AT
DIFFERENT TIMES WE ALWAYS
REMINISCE ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCES
AND MEMORIES OF THAT EXPERIENCE.
I WILL TRULY MISS TOM AND HIS
KINDNESS AND HIS SMILE I ASKED
THAT WE INJURE IN THE MEMORY OF
DR TOM RIVERA. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA MYSTERONS YOU TOO ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THIS GERMAN. THANK
YOU KNOW THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
MAJORITY LEADER- AND I STAND
UNITED WITH YOU IN HONORING A
GREAT. A GREAT MAN A GREAT
PRESENCE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE I
ALSO RISE TO- THAT WE ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF DR
TOM RIVERA. TOM WAS A KIND OF
HUMAN BEING WE ALL ASPIRE TO
BECOME. HE POSSESSED AND
PRACTICE INTEGRITY COMPASSION
RESILIENCY IN A DEEP COMMITMENT
TO JUSTICE AND EQUALITY. HE DID
NOT STOP HELPING OTHERS ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO HIS COMMUNITY
DURING HIS LIFETIME. AS HIS
LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO LIVE ON
WITH PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE INLAND
EMPIRE- FUTURE LEADERS PROGRAM
AND OTHER PROGRAMS HIS PRESENCE
WILL LIVE ON IN OUR COMMUNITY
FOR TIME IMMEMORIAL. MR RIVIERA
MYSELF CROSS PASSES I WAS A
STUDENT AT CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SAN BERNARD DINO. MOVING FORWARD
THERE AND WE BECAME FRIENDS OVER
THE YEARS AND SUPPORTING
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT HE HAD
MOVING FORWARD I REMEMBER HIM
AND HIS- AND A STAFF MEMBER
RANDY PUSHING SO HARD FOR THE
FUTURE LEADERS OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE THE PROGRAM THAT WAS
THERE. THAT WE ENDED UP HAVING-
SPONSORSHIPS AND DIFFERENT
THINGS MOVING FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAD FUTURE IN
EDUCATION TO SECURE THEIR DREAMS
AND MOVING FORWARD. DR TOM
RIVERA BELIEVES STRONGLY IN THE
LIFE CHANGING VALUE OF
EDUCATION. AND HE DEDICATED
HIMSELF TO MOTIVATING IN
ASSISTING YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET
THE OPPORTUNITY OF A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. HE GENEROUSLY GAVE OF
HIS TIME AND EXPERTISE TO
NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS. AND TO
OUR COMMUNITY HIS PRESENCE AGAIN
WILL LIVE ON IN OUR CONDOLENCES
TO- LILY RIVIERA DR LILY RIVIERA
ANOTHER EDUCATOR AND PIONEER IN
OUR AREA THE INLAND EMPIRE.
DOCTOR RIVIERA WILL ALWAYS HAVE
A PRESENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
HE WILL BE A CONTINUED ROLE
MODEL FOR ALL CULTURES AND
DIVERSITIES TO ATTAIN TO ATTAIN
THEIR DREAMS AND HIGHER
EDUCATION I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF DR TOM RIVERA.
THANK YOU MYSTERONS. AND DR
WEBBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF TRACIE
RHONDA MORRIS A BELOVED MENTOR
BROTHER FATHER HUSBAND
GRANDFATHER AND FRIEND WHO
TRANSITIONED SUDDENLY LAST MONTH
ON TUESDAY FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH AT
THE AGE OF FIFTY FOUR. TRACY WAS
HOME GROWN HE ATTENDED
ELEMENTARY MIDDLE HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE AND MY DISTRICT IN
OUR COMMUNITY. THE COMMUNITY
THAT HE LOVED AND CHERISHED. HE
IS ALSO A UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN TRAINED AS AN AVIATION
ELECTRONICS SPECIALIST. TRACY
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
GIVING BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY TO
OPEN DOORS AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHER AFRICAN
AMERICAN MALES. IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN TRACY MORRIS FOUNDED
THE BLUE HEARTS FOUNDATION A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
FOCUSES ON UNDER SERVED YOUTH
AGES THIRTEEN TO NINETEEN.
THROUGH HIS MENTORSHIP AND
DEDICATION TRACY WAS ABLE TO TAP
INTO THESE YOUNG BOYS AN UNSEEN
POTENTIAL THAT MANY NEVER
THOUGHT THEY HAD. IN LESS THAN
TEN YEARS THE BLUE HEART
FOUNDATION EXPOSE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YOU TO PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
WORKSHOPS COLLEGE CAMPUS TOURS
THE ARTS VOLUNTEERISM AND THEY
HAD A 100% ACCEPTANCE RATE TO
COLLEGE FOR THEIR STUDENTS UPON
GRADUATION FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
TRACY WILL BE MESSED AND AVOID
HIS MENTEES ARE FEELING AT HIS
SUDDEN LOSS OF LIFE IS
TREMENDOUS. THE BLUE HEART
FOUNDATION HAD BEEN HIS LIFE'S
WORK AND ONE THING IS CLEAR. HIS
WORK WILL CONTINUE THROUGH THE
BLUE HEART FAMILY TO CONTINUE
REACHING THOSE IN NEED AND TO
CONTINUE BEING A PILLAR OF
SERVICE AND MENTORSHIP. TRACY
WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE DIVINE
NINE FAMILY HE WAS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE OMER KHAN IOTA
SIGMA CHAPTER OF PI BETA SIGMA
FRATERNITY INCORPORATED. TRACY
MORRIS IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
APRIL MORRIS HIS DAUGHTER ASHLEY
LET HIS GRANDDAUGHTER AND MANY
MANY MANY FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
TODAY I WORE BLUE IN TRACY'S
HONOR AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR WEBBER THANK
YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. ALL REQUEST
RICHARD IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY SECOND.
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH
TWENTY THIRD CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY FOURTH
FOUR SESSIONS AT NINE AM. ALL OF
THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS AYE
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MS REYES MOVES DR WEBER
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.